huddled in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
along with a few of our other listeners
and viewers in the snowstorm of
Nashville which by the way is about an
inch deep but now millions think it's a
foot deep but it's not really is Alex
from Washington DC stopping by to say hi
what's up Alex hey Dave how's it going
better than I deserve
how can I help awesome so I have a
question about paying off some debt that
isn't mine I personally became debt-free
about a year ago but my dad has a Parent
PLUS loan to the tune of $55,000 for my
education and so my question is do I pay
that off just now I've been saving up
money I don't know if I should do my
personal fully funded emergency fund
first or should I go ahead and just
knock out the debt before I move on um
why are you paying off his loan he
defaulted on it immediately when I
graduated about seven years ago and yeah
I gave him your book for Christmas last
year but you know what can you do so
he's broke yes okay so the loans but
your name is not on the line my name is
not on Luna once the was the loan when
you guys did the loan were you aware of
it and did you have a handshake that you
promise to pay it or something like that
no I think his intention was to pay it
okay all right it's just he's not able
he's out of control he doesn't handle
things well yeah so you feel like you
want to do this for him okay well let's
kind of think through this a second how
old are you I'm 28 okay I don't think
you've got a moral obligation you
certainly don't have any legal
obligation this is really an act of
generosity is really what it amounts to
and so you got a great heart it's
wonderful that you want to do something
to help your dad and he did something to
try to help you and did it wrong and
thank self in a mess and probably got a
bunch of other mess and he probably
still gonna be a mess even if you pay
this off and so forth so I'm not sure it
really even helps him much because he's
probably got enough other stuff going on
okay that's bad
so it's an act of generosity and
generosity is typically other than a
a tithe if you're an evangelical
Christian Orthodox Jew off the top to
your to your house of worship to your
local church
other than that generosity is done from
surplus and so you would definitely get
the other side of your emergency fund
and start your investing in other words
I think it's a good idea and I'm with
you I think I probably would want to do
it I I'm gonna connect with your heart
on that but I'm not in any hurry sure
the the other part of it is I do have a
pretty good income so I didn't know if
this is your income I take home about
175,000 you're killing it what do you do
I'm actually a boudoir photographer Wow
yes well done thank you awesome
well that helps that does that does
enter into the equation what that means
is you're gonna be able to have that
surplus exact faster exactly okay yeah
let's get the emergency fund in place
get the 15% baby step forward going into
your retirement and then above that if
that's one of the things you want to do
as an act of generosity you can probably
do it in about a year
okay and I was thinking I don't know why
I'm just that's wonderful and who knows
your income may even go up from there
yeah it should this year I also I have
my retained earnings in my business so I
kind of I kind of feel personally that I
have that emergency fund already and at
the end of February I should have enough
to just wipe it out but I didn't know if
I need a personal and a business
emergency fund or you should have both
okay okay but because we want the
emergency fund for the business is not
purely emergency fund it's used for
growth and other things as well in your
case maybe equipment purchases please
yeah and making sure that you you know
in a Down month you can cover cash flow
and that kind of thing and then your
personal emergency found obviously for
personal but I do think you know within
24 months regardless of what other stuff
we put on this income you're still gonna
be able to get to the 55 yeah okay so
you're gonna be right there and that
would be nice I if I'm you it's a very
difficult conversation to have with
parents when they're misbehaving with
money but I would attempt if you can sit
down face to face it's always more
productive to put some strings with this
gift
I'll pay this off if you'll go through
Financial Peace University yeah that
would be I would love if he would show
that you know and I'm gonna try to help
you but I I otherwise that I kind of
feel like I'm throwing good money after
bad because it's like I can't fill up
the hole faster than you can dig it that
is a great point you know and so I I
want to help you I want to see you win
and I'm grateful for all you've done for
me as a dad and for the help in my
education and all that so I want to pay
this off and I'm sitting here with my
checkbook I'm gonna send it direct to
them by the way but but but you know the
only thing I ask is is that you agree to
go through Financial Peace University if
you'll do that for me I'm alright that's
Jack right something like that I mean
just kind of play it where it's not too
harsh like we're smacking him around or
something you know cuz he's not gonna
take that probably but but if we can
guide him and get some get some good for
him out of this rather than you just
kind of over here on the side knocking
stuff out you know I'm saying
I completely agree so well done thank
you so much Don good for you thanks for
dropping by thank you